OpenAI have just released the Codeex app
on Windows finally. So you can get the
full C codeex app experience on Windows.
Now um what this means essentially is
you get this coding agent that you can
download. It's actually available for
free on Windows as well as Mac. So if
you haven't come across this before,
basically Codeex is a really powerful AI
coding agent and it's kind of like an ID
where you can paste in the projects you
want to create and then switch between
APIs and build whatever you want. So
I'll show you exactly how this works.
So, if you want to get access to codeex
on Windows, you can go right here and
then download it. It's available on Mac
already, but it's been available for
quite a while on there. And then from
here, you want to go to Codeex like you
can see. And inside here, basically,
just to give you a quick overview,
you've got these different projects that
you can run on the left hand side. And
then you can set up separate folders for
the projects you want to create. Now,
you could use this for example to create
games, tools, apps, websites, landing
pages. Let me show you an example of
what we've previously. So if we say like
open this up on this particular project
that we coded out and for this we
actually said like you know build out a
calculator as you see for our AI profit
boarding members. If you say open this
up once it's finished coding you can say
yes open up and then it'll actually open
up the project you've built directly
inside your chrome browser here. So you
can quickly preview stuff and build them
out. And if you switch to codec spark
this is really really fast as an API and
again it is available for free. So you
can see
this is available to try with the free
and go plans. And here's how it works.
Right? So let's say for example I wanted
to rebuild my website. Well, I can
easily do that with codeex. So, I can
take all the content from this page here
that I want to redesign. I can then go
back to codeex here. I can create a new
project with a new folder. So, if we go
back over here and we say, okay, AIPB
website, hit create, open that up. That
will start a new um section right here.
Now, you can have multiple agents coding
at the same time, which is pretty simple
and easy to use, which means you can
build multiple projects. And then now we
can start a new thread inside that
folder, right? which also means that if
we have one folder that we're working
on, we can have multiple agents working
on the same projects at the same time to
improve for example like the UI or debug
it etc. So if we go inside the chat here
we can paste in the content for my
website and we can say okay create a
beautiful
landing page for this website.
Make it fun, interesting. use my brand
colors and I'll insert my brand colors
right here
for my AI profit boardroom community
text to use below. Right? So you can
just give you the examples of the text
you want to use and then you can switch
between APIs here. Right now if you want
something super powerful then you would
go with GPT 5.3 codeex. Right? So codeex
is like the most powerful version. And
if you wanted the highest settings for
that switch to extra high over here.
Now, if you want something that's really
fast, so for example, I'm showing you a
live demo right here. Then I can just
select medium on the reasoning effort
and select codec spark, which is the
fastest version of their coder. And then
if we hit send like so, we can start to
code that out, right? And you can see
how quick it is when it actually um
starts using it. Now, it also uses
skills. So, you see here it says read
front-end design skill. What this means
is essentially it's calling on the
skills we've installed, which I'll come
on to in a minute, to build this out.
And now it's actually working on
creating that. All right. And now it's
actually created the page, too. So,
let's just say open this up. And boom,
we've got the page ready to go right
there. Now, if you wanted to make that
look better, so if you look at this,
you're like, it's okay, but it's not
amazing, right? Then you can give it an
example of what you actually want. So,
you can take screenshots and then plug
those into
codeex and say, hey, create it create it
more like this or make it look more
beautiful like this. Right? So, if we
zoom out of this page, we'll take the
whole design. We'll copy the image.
Then, we'll go back to codeex here.
paste this in the the section. So, we
can click on add photos and files and
then we can go to our desktop, grab that
image of the screenshot we just took
or we can grab them both. Open those up
and say make it look more beautiful and
interesting like this. And then we'll
switch to GPT513 codeex to load the
images. Bear in mind you can't use
images on codec spark. Just something to
be aware of there. So you want to switch
APIs back to GPT 5.3 codeex and then it
will start to restyle the page and
redesign it based on the new style that
we want. Right? And then the the cool
thing about this is you can quickly get
like a basic design with codec spark.
And once you've done that then you can
improve and add the final touches for
better UI using GP5.3 codeex. Now you
can also see here you can switch between
different permissions. So you can go
with the default permissions or you can
actually give it full elevated access to
your local files. So this is coding out
locally and then it'll begin to code
this out as you can see. Now whilst
that's waiting you could switch to
another project. So you could go over
here and be like right okay now open
this one up or let's have a look at
this. Right. So if we say open this up
now we'll open up a previous project
that we've created over here. Here's an
example as well. We created like an
invoice generator. And if you want to
see the actual code on the right hand
side, then you can click on view and
toggle diff panel and that will allow
you to see all the code that you've
generated so far. Now in the top left
hand side, we can switch between skills
and automations. So with the skills,
what this allows you to do is just add
more skills and tools to codeex to make
it more powerful. Right? So if we have a
look for example here, we can switch
between like Cloudflare, we could add
that. We could set up the chat GPT apps
option. We could add separate tools like
for example notion and netleifi deploy.
What netleify deploy allows you to do is
actually deploy web projects. So if you
code anything directly inside codeex you
can get connect netify and then build it
out. And that's the newer version of the
website as you can see which looks
better than the original. It's still
honestly it's it's still not as good as
claude code or um claude 4.6 six sonnet
or Opus, but for something that's free,
for something that you can quickly use
to create prototypes. Um, it does work
quite nicely as you can see, right? And
it it works well and it's fast. So, you
can also, for example, like add PDFs.
You could create your own like
presentations using the create, edit,
and PDFs tool right here. And then, if
you wanted to install a skill, you just
click on the plus sign here. It's a
one-click refresh. So, we just refresh
the page here. And now we've got the
skill loaded for creating and editing
PDFs, right? It's as simple as that for
setting up these new skills. Now also
inside the automation section here what
we do
is we can schedule tasks each day right
so let's say for example we wanted to
schedule a new blog post on our website
well we can just go to automations click
on new type in the name of the project
and the task you want to schedule give
it the folder that you want it to run
locally and then say okay create a new
blog post every day right so if we say
okay create a new blog post on my
website daily and then we say, "Right,
okay, do this every day." So, it's on a
daily schedule. Do it at 9:00 a.m. each
day.
Give it a name and then you can just
create the schedule task and it will run
as long as you've got codeex running in
the background. Right? As you can see
here, nine active runs. So, it's pretty
cool. There's so much you can do with
this. It's quite an underrated tool. You
can even, for example, use it to help
you set up something like openclaw.
Right? So over here we actually said
install open claw and enable codeex and
then it created um a setup for openclaw
right here. So actually set it up got it
working and then starts running it
inside our browser. So there's really no
limit to this. It can help you set up uh
agents. It can create and code websites,
landing pages, games, etc. You can have
multiple agents working at the same
time. You can add the automations for
daily schedule tasks and you can add new
skills that just connect it to whatever
you want. So you can automate whatever
you want as well. Okay. And that's
basically how it works. Now inside the
settings as well, if you go over here,
you can also add MCP servers. MCP
servers just allow you to connect this
to other tools externally as well. Kind
of like skills but in a different way.
You can connect GitHub as well. And
there's a bunch of like basic
configurations and that sort of thing.
So that's basically how codeex works. So
thanks so much for watching. If you
haven't already, check out the AR profit
boardroom. We've got lots of video notes
on codec inside here. So, if you type in
codeex at the top, you can get access to
all our best trainings on OpenI Codeex
and how to use it. Um, how to use it
with OpenClaw and Codeex CLI, how to use
Codeex 5.3 with OpenClaw as well. So,
that's all inside the AI profit
boardroom. And this is an AI automation
community that's focused on helping you
save time, scale, and grow learning AI,
right? So, inside the community, you can
ask questions, get help, get support
whenever you need it. You can also get
access to a daily accountability group
if you struggle with information
overload and overwhelm. Additionally,
you can meet loads of cool people doing
similar things to you. And we actually
have over 104 pages of people winning
with this. Right? So you can see here,
for example, Robert said, "I joined the
AR profit yesterday. You built a great
community. Enjoying going through all
the trainings." You've got, for example,
Eduardo who made loads of pro progress
as you can see since joining as well.
And you can also see, for example,
Russell, he's selling AI avatar videos.
based on the training inside the AR
profit boardroom. So if you want to get
access to all of BS trainings, an
amazing community, you can meet people
in your local area. You also get weekly
video coaching course. You can jump on
live Zoom calls and meet the community,
ask questions, share your screen in real
time. You can do that all inside here.
Additionally, you get access to my best
training. So for example, how to go from
beginner to with AI automation in just 5
weeks and learn how to build your first
AI agent in under 5 minutes.
Additionally, you'll get my playbook on
the best automations I use. So for
example, how I automate X and shorts and
Instagram and how I create AI avatar
videos like you can see. Additionally,
you can get daily updates inside this
section. So I look at all the updates
that came out this week and then I'm
like right these are the most important
ones. So you can see I update this daily
with new guides, new video tutorials,
etc. And then if you want to get more
agency clients, you can check out this
section. If you want to watch about the
coaching course, you can do that over
here. If you want to learn how to rank
number one with AI SEO, we've got a full
playbook there. And then we also have a
full road map on how to grow your
YouTube channel with AI based on what's
working for me. So that's all inside the
AI profit board link in the comments
description or go to the
ariprofrofit.com.